hi my name is Minnie champagne I'm
individualization team warframe this
year we'll talk about the overview of
labeling function in Mathematica
hello everyone welcome to my session and
then it's men and I'm in I'm a member of
the visualization team here in the
Wolfram so today would be my third time
giving a talk about labeling system in
visualization so so lab was my original
title automatic level in in
visualization and I decided to add an
overview on top of these because they
are actually a lot of things to talk
about and I just want you you know pick
an angle police so I would like to kind
of introduce you to the visualization
I'm the labeling in the visualization
with these five W's so first thing is
that we're at the automatic labeling
used and then why we why we are doing
the automation at all and then what are
automated and then we talked about how
they automated that's a big question
mark so I I will give you some flavor of
it but we won't go to the detail and
then when were these features brought
out in the sense of the versions right
so here I just I'm trying to build a
case for you that why we are doing all
these so I just found some examples from
the Mathematica or the water language
and also from the internet I can open
this that's the problem of having two
optimized
right so this is just an example from
the Geographics this is a map that is
probably one of the many applications
that labeling is heavily used and we
actually didn't label the cities or the
country names in whorfin technology this
is just straight from whatever the map
source we have what I'm trying to show
you that you know why we are doing this
again and also here is an example from
the internet it is a map and this map
has mixed type of labels one is just
direct labeling and we also can see the
call-outs and there are also the
substitutes in the legends for the
smaller areas another example is from
the GIS there are points and some
information is interested for the
creator so these are other applications
related to the map another example is
the star chart which if I can open this
this is from the warfarin alpha this is
another type of applications that is you
have many points in the vicinity but you
don't actually label all of them you
only label some features in this case it
will be the brightest stars or on data
analysis this is just a random pie chart
I found on the Internet and you can see
the labels the call-outs or this list
line flood the the labels are put
directly on top of the curve
on another type he is done in a diagrams
in these cases anatomy no matter is the
human or you know the dog that we
supported in this version the labels are
crucial to understand or to have more
information for them to be useful so
those are the just some flavours of the
applications why we are doing that and
then why we are doing the automation at
all mostly because the freehand Limbo
labeling is very time-consuming and very
hard to reproduce especially in the
orphan language all the labels we are
doing can you know distilled down to the
text which is a flavor of an insect and
so that's what you essentially have to
do and what I essentially have to do to
put the labels in the graphics and if
you have a set of points that you want
to label then you will have to know the
syntax of the text and then we solve any
algorithm running it's as long as the
points started to gather together or
it's packed
then it's tested to have some labels run
running into each other so the
automation here would be the goal the
goal is to try to find the labels
positions for them so that they don't
run to it long into each other with all
that said how many times have you
created your own visualizations with
graphics so most of them use the
visualization functions in Mathematica
or open language with these high-level
visualization functions like the plot
this plot etc so if you want to add
labels in these visualizations you would
have to use prologue prologue or you
have to understand how to use the show
and control your graphics and like in
this case I have to
I had I had to go through some
iterations to put the labels layer for
them to make sense so it would be really
nice if you have just some automatic way
to put the labels and the let the last
point I want to bring up is that if you
have some very dense information that
you want to show in the visualization
labeling can quickly become the main
task for you to create a visualization
just imagine that if there's no any
automations going on how you are going
to put the labels for this plot to show
off the data the time you spend on
labeling will be just out of proportion
so I hope I've convinced you that there
is a case here and so now I want to talk
about that what are automated in this
time in the wulfing language we have
done a lot of special case special cases
for different scenario so I'm just
trying to find some very representative
examples to tell you that what we have
done so the first type is a line label
in typical plot if you have multiple
curve curves and all you need to do is
put the plow labels go to automatic then
the function names will be picked up and
put it on the app and right-hand side of
the curves at the end of the curves and
then the automation here is that they
are positioned so that they don't run
into each other say my automations so
there are cases that you want to put the
labels inside the plot and just to point
to some features of the function and all
you need to do is just specify the
leader position here I only specify the
x position which is pi and the y
position is automatically computed here
and I want to make the case here is that
these two plots the difference is the
right one has a higher frequency
so the labels is automatically adjusted
so it doesn't run into the curve so but
the syntax is the same or you can give
some name named place like above below
such kind and this is going to be
automatically placed so I have some
bonus examples for you to explore right
and so that was the line label in so by
the way that is just for the plot I took
for the examples all the curve
functional curves labelings
are in the same fashion we have
supported and that 2d and 3d points
labeling the 2d point labeling is
probably the first automated labeling
problem we have tagged out in the ears
so here is just 50 random points and
point to 50 random words and you can see
that the algorithm is play on placing
the labels in a way that they don't run
into each other and here I want to show
off that list three plots are just the
normal distribution with different
standard deviation so the points are you
know kind of scattered or a very dense
in center area I fix the flower range to
make my point that when they are more
space to put the labels so they don't
run into each other in the points then
you can see more labels this this is all
done automatically another example is in
future space plot which is also point
level in I want to tell you that the
labels you know this is water language
you can put any expressions of the label
here is image
and we also introduced options called
label in size in 11 probably eleven
point three because if your label is
image sometimes you may want to decrease
the size or increase the size of the
image and then correspondingly you get
different tens of information or labels
we do the same thing for the 3d points
this is at least point plot 3d so the
same fashion and it just works like that
I want to mention that this avoidance is
only for the current viewpoint so once I
start with what headed the label was
stay put another something bonus for you
to explore and the next one is the
parametric curve
so when with this when we develop the
labeling for the curve we quickly
realized that parametric curve is a
different beast so this has been
supported since version I mean in the in
this version version 12 here is a three
curves parametric curves they don't
overlap so the labels are automatically
put in the fashion that they don't run
into each other nor running into the
axes this is another example which
should have been three to begin with
that the previous example the three
curves didn't overlap but at least two
curves overlap so I want just to just
want to show the the functionality here
that the labels are able to find the
position so that they don't run into it
run into each other and they are not
ambiguous and right so that this is my
intention to increase the pedals of that
blue curve you can see that we
successfully found another position so
it is
nicely labeled right so semi automations
for parametric curve is that you can
also specify where you want to put the
labels in in a very easy way so I'm just
using fold to create a nested call-out
so this is the label then this is the
label position which is just the U value
the parameters value the Samson we also
extend it to a parameter class 3d and of
course the point is that so that the
label the labels don't run into the
curve yes yes so if you don't specify
viewpoint they will give you the default
width viewpoint and the labels is placed
or so it doesn't run to the curve and if
you rotated it will run to the curve for
sure but if you specify the viewpoint in
the input in the options then it will
run the algorithm based on that view
points yes the next one is the region
labeling parametric plot when you
specify two variables then you will
create a region the algorithm is used
here to place the label as well and this
is a bit boring it's just one region
when all right I will get to the point
but here you can also specify the XY
position in the plot and the leader is
going to just appoint you the closest
point on the boundary so you may ask
that what if I put the label the inside
the region yes there will not there will
not show a leader for you so will just
be in the region and in this case that
we have multiple regions the automation
done here is that again it doesn't run
into each other and is pointing to the
other region so it's not ambiguous the
same scene extended to the region plot
and here this is a good case to show you
if we in this case there's no good point
to put two labels on the right-hand side
without any ambiguity so you can just
tell the call-out position is one to put
before one put the after so that's
that's that and then in the version
twelve we also have the surface labeling
for the plus 3d the automatic position
for here is just on top of the plot and
you can also specify the XY position the
Z position will be calculated and the
leader will point to the survey space on
the normal of that point and this is
just natural class 3d we have done this
for the revolution plus 3d and spherical
plot so the last category is the
labeling in the charting system we have
the labeling for Charlie and since
version seven and a long way we have
updated it and the automations here is
that the labels are layered in a way
that they don't run into into each other
and this is all you know algorithmically
wrong so if I reevaluate this this will
be you know different and um you can
also put the labels if you don't say
they want to put it in the call-out by
default it's going to put it in the X's
this looks terrible because they you
know the text we preserve the size of
text I'm intentionally
but with these new options you can
specify the labeling size for that this
may not be the best example to show of
labeling size but if your label is
actually images and this is the same
plot the only difference here is the
image size right so on the left hand
side is 200 and the right has a 400 you
can see that we thought any further
specification the image label are
resized to automatically based on the
bar size
we also done some automation automation
for pie charts labeling it has been an
issue for the pie chart labeling because
when the pie is very small
those crowded labels will run into each
other and now we have done the way so
that it will kind of like spaced out
very similar to the plot we have done
this for the bubble chart as well since
I'm running out of times I'm just
continue and so I want to talk about how
it delays there are a few messes we have
implemented the first one is image
processing tools that we have used under
the hook right and this has been done so
this is at the plot we have seen before
so the image processing is used in the
line label in just and the tools we use
is like the basic image operations open
close
erosion die rate and dilation and we
also use that on the parametric curves
so what we did here is that we use the
image processing to leave out the
intersections and we only consider
points that not intersect optimization
we use fine minimum to solve the problem
like in the multiple curves and also the
pie chart labels in so the constraints
is just like so the labels don't want to
each other and all the labels needs to
be resided in the play range and we also
use computational geometry
functionalities to calculate where the
positions should be in the region case
and then this is the point of future
labeling problem
algorithm we have used so this operation
is the one that run to this point
labeling so they are choosing the
positions so they don't want to each
other yes and there are some other
algorithms we have used or you know
developing in-house like the plus VD
this is a typical problem so we have to
be creative so this is the one we use
the service normal trying to do that we
are this is still the first card we are
trying to improve it along the way and
we also have the time line plot in bar
chart they are on their own in terms of
automations I will see more examples
there I want to talk about the label
visibility we introduced it in version
12 this is an option that we realize
that we really need these along the way
that is so we have a final control to
say that when do we want to see the
labels no matter what and this is just
straight up front documentation right
and so these are two examples here I
think it make the point that is that if
you say that label visibility going to
all then your you're going to show the
labels no matter what even it's running
into other labels and if you say that
every label has infinity priority or
visibility they were trying
they were trying their best but not
wrong any running into each other right
so the last thing I want to mention is
that all these algorithms are based on
some factories of course the size of the
labels and also the size of the image
and also the plow range so if you set
the image size differently then you will
get more labels right so so when are
these when were these functions Road out
so I made a timeline flat Felice
so at version 7 we had the child labels
labeling function and that was the
introduction but the charging functions
and inversion aid when we had a
financial chance we have event labels
and here we do something different so
and then we have ten line cloud and in
version 10 then we introduced plow
labels in version ten point four that's
the the time we have the automation
started so we updated the label and we
updated all the labeling functions and
the player was in sets of the plots and
we introduced the call-out that makes
another update and then we introduced
the label label in size in eleven point
three at that point we include the
features features face plot 3d version
and at this point plus 3d and in this
coming version we the data is just made
up don't quote me so we have label
visibility and we do we did another
update for for all the reasons we and we
kind of integrated the labeled with
call-out internally you may not notice
but I know that and then we we added a
lot of support for parametric plot all
applaud all these plots and if you are
familiar with work with warfarin
language this is actually probably 30%
or 40% of the all of these functions our
plan is that we will gradually roll out
the functionalities to all the
visualization functions which are not
just done by our team so we are working
on that with all the developers right
since I'm out of time I want to leave
these two examples to you which are the
copies from the last year's talk if you
have the beta the conference beta this
example have some snafus I mean it may
not run on your computer but it will run
fine on 11.3 this is just an examples to
showcase that you know how labeling can
be used
combined with the Geographics and all
the entity or the
from warfarin otha and I say this kind
of like right in time because I was
listen to the NPR the other day and it
was saying that United States has the
largest or your production larger than
both Russia and Saudi Arabia so you can
see that clearly here and the other one
is the all the labels are shown in my
best examples they are plan
there is nothing customized to it but
you can really customize the labels a
lot change the background change the
appearance ad in the markers or that so
there's whole galleries of the labels
you can see in the marketing page so
that will conclude my talk thank you
very much
[Applause]